a través de las redes sociales se
multiplican videos como estos donde se
vea jóvenes defendiendo ideales y
valores nacionalistas en León leagepag
es el principal movimiento de
ultraderecha se basa en la generación de
identidad y busca transmitir mensajes
anti inmigración en Francia 1500
personas pertenecen a movimientos de
ultraderecha según las autoridades
grupos que no son reconocidos en ningún
partido político
de hecho estas personas están
desilusionadas con el partido de
reagrupación nacional
consideran que el camino electoral que
han elegido Marín le pen y eriksen no
resolverá nada Solo la fuerza paga el
gobierno disuelve regularmente ciertos
grupos pequeños como bastión social en
el 2019 o los en París en 2022 pero
renacen rápidamente y de manera
fragmentada el grupo Argos Francia
también se proclama heredero de
generación de identidad con los mismos
métodos de propaganda su página de tiene
5.000 seguidores según europol el 46% de
las detenciones en Casos de terrorismo
corresponden a la ultraderecha en
Francia una figura relacionada con el
islam radical
la ultraderecha representa menos acción
y esta gente no tiene los medios de los
islamistas radicales y nuestra
organizada en Red están aisladas que no
tienen los mismos medios económicos
pero no debería hacerte sonreír es algo
que los servicios de inteligencia se
toman en serio pero no es el principal
peligro que amenaza a Francia otro
ejemplo es el good que nació
originalmente En 1968 y anunciado su
regreso a las redes sociales nunca se
disolvió realmente a veces vuelve al
escenario público como en marzo de 2022
cuando el exjugador de rugby argentino
Federico Martín aramburu fue asesinado a
manos de un ex